the sushi science show clips
like we've spoken about intervening at
early stage of life but obviously
there's a lot of research looking at
trying to
um like these regenerative medicine or
Rejuvenation Technologies later in life
to help alleviate different
age-associated diseases and so I was
just wondering like to you what do you
think are the main or like most
promising strategies in terms of
rejuvenative approaches
oh I don't know I mean
I mean we uh we really don't understand
what Rejuvenation means actually
so like even the clocks uh
the kind of Aging clocks all of the
clocks have been developed so far they
are aging clocks so they quantify uh the
direction from The Young to the Old
State uh
whether they would work in the opposite
direction actually it's unclear it's
it's
commonly used and so we use of course as
well and we kind of assume that uh if we
uh
subject a system biological system like
cell so minus so some treatment and
observe a decreased biological age we
assume it's Rejuvenation uh
think there's one component of that is
Rejuvenation but not not not the entire
kind of response so
what I what I'm thinking is that we need
to develop
um
clocks that would be more tuned to to
test for Rejuvenation so some kind of
Rejuvenation clocks such clocks do not
exist yet and because when we look uh
pnb kind of think about the aging
process and quantify it
this clocks would necessarily be a
composite kind of composite clocks uh
some changes each other changes would be
would would be damaging would be true
aging some would be neutral changes but
they still could quantify the Asian
processes and some would be adaptive
like we call of adaptive or protective
changes that uh that are activated in
response to HLA HTTP changes like the
kind of the system finds a new
homeostatic state in a way so they could
still quantify aging but they would have
nothing to do with respiration
so I sometimes give this a metaphor of
using
um
adaptive changes in the form of like a
glasses or hearing aid or like a walking
cane or some some other features and we
could develop potentially a clock based
on this uh you may be collect uh
parameters maybe 10 or 20 parameters
like that and give away to each
parameter and quantify AG I think it you
know would be quite reasonable accuracy
and then we would fire all of the
doctors there's no doctors no glasses no
hearing aid and based on this everybody
is rejuvenated because the way but it's
not yeah so this means that uh agency
changes have many many features and only
some of them committify truly represent
aging and therefore would represent
Rejuvenation so when they apply existing
clocks and we see Rejuvenation there's a
clear leaders component of it but it
cannot be 100 sure because we don't know
the contribution
I don't know if it's explained clearly
or not but anyway so we need a new
generation of chili Clarks which are
specific for Rejuvenation they simply do
not exist and I don't think anybody at
least I haven't heard people even kind
of conceive in this idea just kind of
asking a question that we need a
different type of Club
and then by using this clock we could we
could address a better address
rejuvenation
so clearly Rejuvenation is possible
because we know this developmental
Rejuvenation Rejuvenation
and I suspect there will be some other
types as well
and we are working on it as well uh but
I think many many labs are working on it
uh and we need to better understand
better quantify it and and then you know
once it's done that we could broaden up
and develop screening approaches and so
on but we just don't have essential
tools yet for that yeah that made us
super interesting and so one question I
was going to ask was how would you like
validate such a Rejuvenation clock but
then I was thinking we've just spoken
about early development in that early
Rejuvenation process is that not
something that we could potentially use
to develop a Rejuvenation clock or not
in the essence of Aging so what do we
mean by age so and if the
again so I may be wrong but this is my
thinking it's a damage right and so if
you focus on quantifying this uh
damage or negative consequence of of
metabolism or being alive then we follow
agent therefore we could follow
Rejuvenation as well based on this if
they are able to distinguish various
agents of the changes what I don't like
is that there are so many papers so many
studies when somebody just looking at
particular Gene for example some
metabolite and absorb okay that Gene
decreased this age let's bring it back
to the useful level and call it
Rejuvenation to me it's simply an
answers we cannot be sure because we
don't know if that data changes negative
positive or neutral it just cannot say
anything based on this we need to
distinguish which one is which uh
and yeah so in general I think
in the Aging field we just need more
kind of fundamental uh studies kind of
uh conceptual studies just kind of
trying trying to define the aging
process because ultimately this is
Essence so many people claim that we
already know everything about uh aging
we just need to develop quickly
interventions I think this is also wrong
we need more fundamental studies we need
more funding into the basic biology of
age
uh not really a translational yet I mean
translation is also good I mean this
this may actually increase funding for
the field but we need basic work we need
to build the foundation for the field
which does not exist
so yeah really well said isn't it
amazing that you know I was at the
conference two years ago and there was a
questionnaire given about to Define
agent the researchers in the field and
everybody gives a different definition
of Aging so it's
just yeah it's just amazing so we
disagree at a very fundamental level so
we need to work on that and really to
try to find consensus or develop do some
experiments to at least to clarify this
this basic basic problem
exactly you know that was really
well-sized and so
um obviously yeah there is a lot of
research and I was just uh wondering
you've done some work on like naked mole
rats you've done work on human cells is
there any multiple organism that you
would love to work on or think would
really help us to address some of these
questions
yeah we're thinking of yeah about other
organisms over the years actually I
worked with maybe 20 different organisms
all the way from bacteria or kia flies
we work on East actually in the lab
currently also it actually is very good
model organisms I really like it single
cell eukaryote that Aegis and so many
things can be done at the very basic
level uh but we are focusing basically
on mice primarily mice and a little bit
on human make more Reds and East
this is our current uh there is one
ongoing project on Axolotl as well so
and actually once yeah you're right
there's a sound that we work
we work on a few
oh yes I guess as this would be an
interesting one to further understand
Rejuvenation right because they have
like lamb regeneration it's like regrets
yeah you're right yeah so and uh do you
want to address the question of the
relationship between uh regeneration and
Rejuvenation that's another big question
in the field in my mind what's the
relationship between these two uh it's
still unresolved right I think there are
some good models for it
um both both mammals but but things like
Axolotl for example as well